[Music]
so much has happened since I last saw
you
I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh and then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
[Music]
Wow you have no idea I love the goddess
of death is invaded as God oh I miss
this
and you know you had a flag race tonight
did I win no I want easily this inside
right that's true
that's God is dead it'll be reborn in my
image I thought you'd be Claire to see
me
near the stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
at the old days
[Music]
surprise this would be such fun
hi
he's a fighter
here we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
by the same unit I'm just a couple of
hotheaded fools yes
I'll collect fire door like water kind
of like fire but a whole like raging
fire so I like smoldering fire I guess
I'm just taking a break we have this
really cool adventure saving earth and I
was pretty happy anyway so I needed some
me time and I came to Australia and
that's when I moved in with Daryl hello
and here we are
oh it's a nice flat as you can see and
we get along well yeah I guess I just
wanted to be around average everyday
people
Daryl is an average sort of everyday guy
so it works out well while I'm here I'm
trying to get involved with the lobby's
who's this purple weirdo surprised who
actually knew that was to give back to
the community
Daryl here is Abuna crafter electronic
letter I Drive into Captain America and
Iron Man this seems to be something very
intense going on between them and I want
to offer my help with my services dear
Tony Stark how's it going
I heard you and Captain America we're
having some relationship problems dear
Steve Rogers do you remember when i
goaded you into killing those prisoners
and you made me swear to never tell the
other Avengers if there's any other
secrets you need kept just let me know
because I'm not up to much what are you
doing later I was just working what are
you doing he's working keep out Daryl
costume for battles the mule Mia over
here taking a nap something I've been
roasting in the Sun for a number of
weeks now it's almost already delicious
question what are Infinity stones a lot
of information and ideas and what I like
to call this will Clues speckles around
the place and who is the man in the
purple chair it's purple is a magic
glove doesn't like
standing up fury what does he really
know and is fury his real name is it
actually pronounced furry little mill
near here there are sunglasses in case
get bright on the Rainbow Bridge which
often it does if you lift up this little
thing
what's he holding me I never wear
cut-offs how do I keep waking up and
come up small new parents going in
cut-offs coming out yoo-hoo hmm oh my
bike we heard from Tony Stark
and Captain America I didn't contact you
I haven't received a single phone call
one second hey t-bone how many times do
we have to go over this no amount of
money is gonna get me to join your
little pissing contest
what yeah talk to Thor yeah he's sort of
been waiting here from you I have him
right here
oh you can't right now okay am I
disappointed that they didn't invite me
to fight with them
no yes touch with you I don't have a
phone he doesn't have a phone
send a raven I just start my own team
team four of course and it would be me
and Darren just us right D yep I can't
pay rent with these things one's a
pumpkin and these Asgardian coins
they're not worth it in Asgard those
coins these coins are worth gazillion
human dollars okay gazillion you're rich
no one will exchange these go to the
market set up a store Yeah right
yeah Asgardian where previously owned by
four I'm the celebrity that will sell
like hotcakes you might need to think
about getting a getting a job yeah I
have a job you know my job is I saved
the planet it maybe you should get a job
mmm I have a job really eating the
machine with the words that come out of
it this is knowledge knowledge is power
no it's not knowledge is not power
that's power the brain is a muscle and
that's a muscle and that's a muscle
there you're all muscles this is all
muscle so I am covered in brains and I
have more brains than you so do you
think maybe we could just think that we
need to serve it I don't think we can
get a search and get a survey we're
getting a seventh ladies and gentlemen
this is what you've become for it
Oh miss this let me put together a team
this team you know
yeah school de revenge's revenge us you
know I mean we don't have to have a name
if you have no name
[Music]
get tickets now
I sense a great change in your future
does something as dire plans for you my
friend
dire plans for destiny
hello the goddess of death is invaded as
god I thought would be glad to see me
as got this dead
you'll be reborn
neither stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so putting together teams
the old days
surprise this will be such fun
did you talk to us
he's a fighter
boosted taka boy
I'm not a cream
any goddess of death
what were you the god of again
they're saying you like just a couple of
hotheaded faults but hawk-like raging
fire
oh I like smoldering fire
[Music]
now I know what you're thinking
how did this happen
well it's a long story
[Music]
Basco is dead
[Music]
either
[Music]
what have you brought today tell me
[Music]
it's main event time
[Music]
[Applause]
we know each other he's a friend from
work
[Music]
[Music]